[Music]
in particular I call upon the people of
the ravaged areas to return to their
home to leave the streets and to permit
the authorities to restore plot and
order that was President Lyndon Johnson
responding to the Detroit riots in 1967
the unrest began after police raided an
unlicensed bar in a black neighborhood
racial tension erupted in and led to one
of the most violent riots in US history
over five days 43 people were killed
more than 7,000 were arrested and
hundreds of buildings were burned to the
ground the new movie the Troy focuses on
an incident at the Algiers motel where
police killed three black men and beat
nine others actor John boyega plays a
private security guard who got caught in
the middle as he tries to assist the
police but the table's turned when they
questioned him as a suspect sometimes
when a black guy's put in a position of
authority other black guys they like to
sing what you out okay because I'm not
supposed to tell them what to do when we
have these conversations we do them in
stages okay
Stage one witnesses stage two suspects
what's do you mean you don't know what
stage where no could you specify for me
yeah mine Stage two John boyega joins us
now here at the Jes John good morning
good morning play then good listen I
want to read something that Rolling
Stone says about this it's a hardcore
masterpiece that digs into our violent
past to hold up a dark mirror to the
systemic racism that still rages in the
here and the now as an actor what kind
of weight comes with this type of
project I think it's it's an interesting
way it's an interesting balance of a few
things I mean number one is the fact
that you're you're basically going back
to a very hard piece of history and you
re-enacting very horrific scenes but at
the same time it's
also the responsibility of delivering
the truth it's specifically the
emotional truth it's also reflect onto
what's going on today and that comes
with responsibility but at the same time
it's it it's important for us for us to
go there what's the truth that this
movie says I mean the truth is is that
systemic racism is it's been a deep part
of American history not only America but
globally and it's just an insight to
racial relations and tensions between
people who haven't you haven't been
given the best opportunity by the system
and that's something that this this
movie explores in a very intricate but
but complex way this is a really intense
movie as a viewer particularly that
scene in the hotel with the nine
tortured the three who are killed yeah
acting that out must have been
incredibly intense for you yeah what was
that like I mean it was it was
definitely intense
because with any movie like this you
have to keep her level of intensity to
assure that there's a an emotional and
emotional truth to the character that
you're playing you you want to make sure
that you're doing them justice as we are
playing real people it's tiring yeah I
get hungry real quick I know but but
it's it's worth it we have an amazing
director in Kathryn Bigelow and she she
stands as the motivation so it all works
out how many takes did you do at that
scene we done a good few it felt to a
certain time that we kept on going and
Kathryn likes to you know leave the
cameras rolled in like two three minutes
over the scene just to get just a
natural energy so it took a while and we
were there in the hardiest motel for a
long time but it was it was worth it I
mean watching it we were like it's it's
worth it you've had strong good roles in
two movie star wars the force awakens
and now this were to get in a lot of
attention yeah you also have spoken out
about diversity and the need for more
actors like you to have an opportunity
to show what they have you have a
feeling that this kind of movie and this
kind will make a difference personally I
mean this is set on a specific story and
so you wouldn't need to to cast black
actors but but for me it's it's about
obviously just making the the
imagination in a bit wider when it comes
behind the scenes
me to have more people behind the scenes
of love diverse origins are just
influence we had the same conversation
yesterday about yeah female directors
yeah yeah we need all of that we the
more we have behind the scenes the more
their perspective influences the the
projects that they put up so hopefully
things will change but this is it's so
specific I think it's it's in its own
world of intensity and then as you said
it is it's it's a history lesson what it
was some directors for me specifically
your miss it's it's craft it's craft the
the the ability to to harness and expose
yourself it in in a way that just sheds
a light on to a character eyes is a
strange thing and it's a it's a weird
feeling and some directors can get that
out of you some can't so I've been I've
been in a great position that all the
directors I've worked with so far have
been pretty good JJ Abrams Rian Johnson
now Katherine it's been I've been kind
of spoiled yeah yeah absolutely and they
all come with their different
perspectives and energies and ways of
working which is which is great for me
as an actor I can tell Hollywood that I
can work with all of them I can do it
John
millions of us Star Wars nerds want to
know the last Jedi comes out in December
who is the last Jedi I don't know I
don't know I'm in the Bubba Fett films
what's next for Finn well definitely a
darker and stronger story I think people
are looking for him to recover from his
back injury and he'll be out the bed and
ready to go fight if you knew would you
tell us
[Laughter]